can we talk a little bit about ptsd and
mdma
there's this fascinating uh paper
came out on a fascinating study that
you're part of
that's a phase three study can you
describe what the study is can you
describe what phase three means
can you describe um what the findings
are and why it's
yeah in fact so important and impactful
yeah this study came out may 10th in
nature medicine so one of the highest
impact
factors in medicine journals it was
tremendous so
to make a drug into a medicine the first
thing you need to do
is what are called non-clinical or
pre-clinical studies meaning
safety established in animals what does
the drug do
what are the side effects in animals
where do you see the risks and
then you negotiate with fda to do phase
one studies
and phase one studies where you move
from animals to humans
and those are more safety studies and
trying to describe what the drug does so
that you can
determine if there is potential medical
value there
certain drugs like cancer drugs
are so toxic
that um you don't have phase one studies
in healthy volunteers
it's like um phase one slash two where
it's you you bring in the patients
but you still are doing sort of dose
response safety studies
but you use patients but most phase one
studies are healthy volunteers
phase two are where you start bringing
in the patients
and you start experimenting with various
different things the purpose of phase
two
is really just to design phase three now
again i'm
sort of putting out of the picture in
another areas mechanism of action how do
these drugs work
phase two you're trying to figure out
what they do
who your patient population is what are
the risks who do you
include who do you exclude what are the
doses what is your treatment
what are your measures
in our case it was you know how do you
do a double blind study
that was a big part of phase two that's
a big challenge for
psychedelic drugs any kind of drugs that
have a real strong effect
you know how do you do a double blind
study a double blind side to interrupt
would mean that
the patient should know should not be
aware whether it's
a placebo or not and the research and
the researcher does not is not aware
and so for that lack of awareness when
the effect is really strong is very
difficult to do on both the research and
the patient side
yes and there sometimes fascinating they
talk about triple blind
so the the other part is the raters that
evaluate the symptoms and
before and after so you ideally want
triple blind you want the patients
the researchers and the evaluators of
the outcomes
all of them not to know what the drug
whether it was drug or placebo and
that's to reduce
experiment or bias so
and then then you move to phase three
once you've figured out how to design
the phase three studies and phase three
are the large-scale
multi-site placebo-controlled
double-blind
studies where you must prove safety and
efficacy
in order to get permission to market the
drug
now for us when we started maps in 86
as i said it was one year after the
criminalization of mdma in 85
we had five different protocols that
were rejected by the fda
for studying with mdma and these were
all various phase one studies
um they came from harvard from uc san
francisco from the university of in
arizona and albuquerque new mexico
all over and they were all rejected 1992
years after we started we got the first
permission for phase one
and that took us through much of the 90s
again
things are slow because we have to raise
the money through donations and
and then in 1999 is when we started the
work with
ptsd and that then
took us till
november 29 2016
which is when we had the end of phase 2
meeting with fda
so it took 30 years from the start of
maps to the end of phase 2 meeting with
fda
and what we had discovered during phase
was several different key points
the drugs that are available right now
for ptsd the
ssris zoloft and paxil that have been
approved by fda
and regulators in europe as well the
european medicines agency
for ptsd they work better in women than
in men
and they failed in combat related ptsd
all right so what we learned is that
mdma-assisted therapy
works just as well in men or women and
it works in combat-related ptsd
it works in regardless of the cause of
ptsd we also discovered that
even though there are stories that you
know people take mdm at raves and they
dance all night and they overheat and
they get hypothermia and they die from
overheating which is true and can happen
from pure mdma
or that sometimes people have heard
about needing to cool down
and so they drink water and then while
they're
dancing all night and then they drink
too much water and then they dilute
their blood and they die from
hyponatremia
so there are risks of mdma but we
discovered that in a therapeutic setting
we can control all those risks those
things don't happen at all
so we discovered safety we could we
could demonstrate safety
we also figured out that our measure
the caps the clinician-administered ptsd
scale that it's the
gold standard all over the world for
measuring ptsd symptoms it's what the
fda and the ema
require we discovered that it was a good
measure for us and that we could show
changes in that the other
big thing that we learned is that um and
we haven't mentioned this
yet but the work in the 50s and 60s with
lsd and psilocybin in the modern
research over the last 20 years with
psilocybin and classic psychedelics has
demonstrated
that there's a link between this
mystical experience this unit of
mystical experience and therapeutic
outcomes
for the treatment of addiction for
working with people's life-threatening
illnesses
you know that for ocd for
obsessive-compulsive disorder that
there's
with the classic psychedelics both in
the 50 years ago and then the research
now has been
that there's a link between the depth of
the mystical experience and therapeutic
outcome
what we discovered is that that's not
the case for mdma
that people do score fairly high on the
scales of mystical experience not as
high as they do with the classic
psychedelics
but they do score pretty high on average
and
a significant number of them have over
the cutoff for what would be considered
a full mystical experience
so enough to say that we could look at a
correlation and we didn't find any
the other thing that we discovered and
this was
more humbling i would say for me
personally
is that my dissertation at the kennedy
school a big part of it was on the it's
about the regulation of the medical use
of psychedelics and marijuana
big part of my dissertation was how to
do the double-blind
study and i thought i'd solve the
problem and i persuaded my
dissertation committee that i'd solved
the problem
and the solution was therapy with
low-dose mdma
versus therapy with full dose mdma and
everybody knows that they're going to
get mdma most of these people have never
done it before
they'll be confused about is at full
dose or low dose
and then the challenge is to pick a dose
that's
high enough so that there is this
confusion but not so high that it's so
therapeutic that we can't tell the
difference between the groups
so we we studied zero meaning inactive
placebo
25 milligrams 30 milligrams 40
milligrams 50 milligrams 75 milligrams
100 milligrams 125 and 150.
what we discovered is that my
dissertation was wrong
and that there is no good solution to
the double-blind problem
um what we found is that to our surprise
actually was that 75 milligrams was an
effective dose
oh wow we didn't think that i mean the
normal doses
like uh full dose is like 125 milligrams
something like that
but 75 milligrams was an effective dose
and we discovered that the lower doses
so i was i was half right you could say
the the doses
of 25 30 40 50 they they could
produce enough confusion that you could
say that they were successful at
blinding not perfectly but
enough confusion so that people
therapists couldn't know for sure so
that
so that there was this reduction of bias
you could say
but what we discovered again to to our
surprise was that the low doses made
people uncomfortable
they they stimulated them
but they didn't reduce the fear and so
people still got better with the therapy
with low-dose mdma but if we gave them
therapy with inactive placebo they did
even better
than if we gave them therapy with
low-dose mdma
so we we call it an anti-therapeutic
effect
well i don't mean to imply that they got
worse but it made people uncomfortable
people didn't like it you know but we
would still help them make some progress
so we had the blinding but what what it
meant by reducing the effect of
therapy with inactive placebo is that it
would make it easier for us to find a
difference between the two groups
and so the real question is if you can
do it with therapy
why bother at a drug so
we went to the fda and and so this was
what we discovered during phase two we
went to the fda
at this end of phase two meeting and we
said we can give you blinding
but it will make it easier for us to
find a difference between the two groups
and so we suggest
that we do therapy with inactive placebo
versus therapy with full dose mdma
that will cause a problem because most
people will be able to tell what they've
got
yeah what um tom lawford a doctor who
used to be head of psychiatry products
at fda is our
main advisor so the first thing he said
is that the double blind
fails in practice a lot even with ssris
because there are certain side effects
that you have with these drugs and the
doctors who are doing these research
when you're
reporting your side effects they can say
oh that's probably you got the active
drug instead of the placebo so
the double blind is in theory is
terrific but in practice
it doesn't always work quite as well yes
and so what tom said is that there are
two
main approaches that they think are
important to reduce bias
the first one is easy to do it's called
random assignment
so you know sometimes there's studies
where you know you'll you'll treat a
bunch of people
with something and some fraction of them
will get better and some won't and then
you say
okay all those who didn't get better who
volunteers to get this new treatment
and then you give them the new treatment
but the people that volunteer are more
likely to want to get better
they're not representative sample of
everybody that has
these so when you have random assignment
everybody is similarly motivated
and has meets the same inclusion
exclusion criteria
so that's what we told we of course we
need random assignment
the other part was when the bias double
blind doesn't work as well
then the system of independent raiders
is especially important of how you do
that so we
have um over a pool of raiders
over 20 of them and we do this monthly
in inter rater reliability tests
to make sure that they um you know
evaluate the so that they're given a
videotape of a ptsd patient and then
they're supposed to rate them
according to their symptoms and then
then we sort of make sure that we've got
this calibrated raider pool
and it's all done by zoom by
telemedicine and they're randomly
assigned to the next person that needs a
rating
so they said 20 raiders yeah so we've
got like 20 raiders
and we want what we want to do is is
make it so that each raider sees each
patient
only once maybe twice but but not
tracking them through the study
so that guys to reduce the bias in the
raiders that they they don't know where
this person is in the study
yes um and then and so
there's a fellow bob temple who's like
the old wise man at the fda he's been
there since 1972
he was in charge of the office of
science policy and they brought him into
the final meeting of this
um process where we were trying to
design
phase three so once fda said yes you can
go to phase three
that was november 29 2016.
we then negotiated for eight months on
the design of phase three and all of the
other information this is fascinating
it's kind of neat this process of design
ah it was
you know to the extent that i have any
uh artistic creativity
it's in protocol design i really love
that so you enjoy this process i love it
i love it because it's always trade-offs
and it's
um yeah it's you know and i acknowledge
you know that that we are
all biased and so how do you there's
something beautiful
about the scientific process designed to
get you to the truth
um especially when that scientific
process is trying to get to the truth of
the human organism which is so
complicated
so it's very difficult to uh to dissect
to do to get the
the the strong effects and when you're
analyzing
when you have like raiders they're
they're watching a video
there's removing subjectivity from that
is very very challenging
yeah very very much so um
and so we came to this agreement with
fda though that we would um
use this uh independent raider pool and
um and so we learned in
in phase two again that the double blind
there was no solution to the double
blind problem and and both the fda and
the european medicines agency
in the end agreed that the best design
was therapy with inactive placebo
versus therapy with full dose mdma
accepting the fact that most people will
be able to tell
what whether they got nothing or they
got full dose mdma
most therapists will be able to tell the
difference but
that makes a harder test for us to show
a difference between the two groups
because we're giving them inactive
placebo and not the anti-therapeutic
effect of low-dose mdma
so once we started phase three so then
we were able to start
in 2018 phase three and the paper
in nature medicine that just came out
was the
results of our first phase three study
we
came to agreement with fda that we would
do two
phase three studies each would have 100
persons in them
and what the fda said to us is that they
thought that we could prove
efficacy with smaller numbers than they
wanted to see
for safety the reason they said that is
that in phase
two we had a large effect size so
from a statistical point of view the
bigger of an effect that you're looking
for the fewer number of people you need
to get statistical significance
when you're trying to find small
differences you need large numbers of
people to
sort of work out the noise um
so we were we came to agreement on two
100 person phase three studies
and the idea is that it's very possible
that the the first part the first study
would show the efficacy
because the effect is so strong yeah
yeah and the second but but also
safety as well so so you know one of the
things we also realized when you work
with a highly stigmatized drug
in the midst of still you know the drug
war and prohibition
that we need highly sympathetic subjects
and we need to make the best case we can
which means
we need to work with the hardest cases
so that this is really needed and so we
end up
enrolling people the first study was
chronic
severe ptsd and unlike many studies of
ptsd we enroll people that have
previously attempted suicide
wow so we have multiple people that have
tried to kill themselves
that we felt like um if we were to
exclude them what are we doing
those are the people that need it the
most so
we we came to this agreement with fda
we're going to work with
chronic severe ptsd patients
including those that had attempted
suicide and
we would do these two 100 person studies
and
we also negotiated what's called an
interim analysis
so what that means is that when the
study
is underway
and often big big studies they have this
kind of interim analysis where what you
do is
and for us we negotiate when we had 60
or 60 people had reached the primary
outcome measure
and all hundred had been enrolled then
we would take a look at the data
and if the statistical analysis that we
did
was showing you know based on a certain
effect size that we chose based on what
we saw in phase two
the interim analysis is for what's
called sample size re-estimation
so what it means is if the results
aren't as good as you thought they would
you can add more people
and then you'll get statistical
significance
it means that your effect isn't as
strong as you thought it'll be harder to
get insurance to coverage but
fda will still approve it because fdl
also believes that
these are group averages there may be
some people that will later figure out
respond better than others
so they'll approve it if it's
statistically significant even if it has
a low effect size
the ssris have low effect size so
we did the interim analysis in march of
and what we discovered to our delight
was that
we did not need to add any subjects
that's all we were told we weren't told
like what is the results we were just
told all we were going to get is a
number
zero or you need to add x numbers of
people to the study to get the
statistical significance that's right
around the time that covet hit
and lockdowns happened and we ended up
negotiating with fda that we would end
the study with 90 people instead of 100.
it took a while for us to end up doing
that so the paper that we just published
is on the results of 90 people
i think it was 46 in the mdma group 44
in the
placebo group and
what we discovered was that the
study worked better than we had even
hoped so
the first thing is that you look at
statistical significance you have to get
0.05
which basically means a nickel out of a
dollar a 1 in 20
chance that the difference between the
two groups
is due to some random factor rather than
to your intervention
and in this case the the placebo group
gets therapy
and then with inactive placebo and then
the
um group gets mdma with active placebo
so you have to get .05 there's another
measure that the fda uses sometimes
called robust
which means one in a thousand instead of
one in twenty
one in a thousand and if you get a
robust results .001
and you meet some other criteria they
might agree to approve the drug on the
basis of just
one phase three study instead of two
because when you think about it
a one in 20 chance for your first
seconds to a phase three study a one in
20 chance for your
second phase three study you multiply
that together it's one in four hundred
point zero um two five um
that's pretty good so robust .001 is
even better than
two independent phase three studies each
at .05
um what we ended up getting was one in
ten thousand point zero zero
zero one outrageous yeah you know
incredibly so that's a measure of both
the difference between the two groups
and the variability
and so what it meant is that we had
minimal variability
that most people who got to mba got
quite a large
amount of benefit from it and most
people who got the placebo
were more or less in the same range as
well that's really exciting by the way i
mean that
i mean i i i suppose it's exciting from
a perspective of
approval by the fda maybe perhaps that's
the way you're seeing it but it's also
the exciting because it's it has a
chance to help people that are truly
suffering
yeah well if we can get one in uh 10 000
in the first phase three study chances
are we can get one in 20 in the second
so it's really going to be about safety
for us in the second phase three study
yeah now you can have
a large uh p value large significance
but you could have an effect that's not
very significant
it's not clinically significant you can
have statistical significance without
clinical significance and as i said the
the more people you get in the study you
can find smaller and smaller differences
between two groups
now we showed that we had um
a very large effect size so effect size
is based on
that scale you mentioned well well the
scale of the effect size
is based on um standard deviations
so an effect size of one means that your
results are one standard deviation away
from the norm
that's considered very large the
the ssris because they have they were
like 0.3.4
effect size that's considered small
effect size medium is starting to be
around 0.6
and 0.8 and above are large effect sizes
um we had um what's called
placebo-subtracted effect size there's
two different ways to look at it
placebo-subtracted means you kind of
look at the difference between your two
groups
and and what that is for us since one
group had therapy and one had therapy
plus mdma the placebo subtracted effect
size
is basically the effect of just the mdma
because you've kind of washed out the
therapy that was 0.91
so we had a large effect size which was
different
wow over so 0.91 over the just the
therapy so over the placebo
yeah wow now when we do the
within group meaning the group that just
got the
mdma plus therapy look at their baseline
and their outcomes
that's another way to look at it and
that's what's going to actually happen
in practice because people are going to
get mdma plus
therapy that's 2.1 effect size two
standard deviations away from the norm
is enormous effect size yeah
the other part is that we had um
no effect by sight which is very
important so we had 15 sites two in
israel two in
canada 11 throughout the united states
the fda looks at is there a side effect
because what that might mean is maybe
you've got all your patients
or most of your patients going to this
one site which is these highly
experienced therapists and they're like
you know hippies from way back and
they're
super experienced with psychedelics and
you know and they're they're getting
great results but nobody else gets good
results
so we had no effect by sight which means
that's incredible
that we've been able to train all these
new therapists we had about
about 80 therapists working at all these
15 sites
we also discovered that there's a group
that's considered to be
very difficult to treat which is called
the dissociative subtype
so when people are traumatized
one of the ways to psychologically
survive that
is you dissociate it's like you're not
there
when you do that though it's hard to
come back because when you come back
then you get all these painful memories
and fearful and so
the extreme of that is called
dissociative identity disorder
kind of like schizophrenia almost
dissociative identity you're
so we let people in who are on the
dissociative
subtype and those are considered to be
the hardest to treat because
the the theory is that you need to be
ego intact as i said the mystical
experience is not correlated with
therapeutic outcomes and
you need to be talking about what
traumatized you and working through that
and expressing it letting it out not
keeping it in so the dissociative
subtype
seems like it's harder for them to get
back into the event because they're so
dissociated what we showed is that those
people did even better on average than
everybody else
so that mdma is integrative it helps
people
who are so separate that they make even
more rapid progress
so it's almost like them dma made it
more difficult for them to dissociate
yes yeah or you could say it made it
easier for them to remember
yes exactly to reverse the dissociation
yeah and we find that mdma
enhances memory for the trauma so that
you can have these
unconscious memories or memories that
you cannot remember
that you've suppressed so much but they
distort your view
your filter of the world is distorted by
these fearful memories that the world
can't be trusted people can't be trusted
it's always about to happen
so we find that mdma increases memory
for the trauma but by reducing the fear
then the memories can come to the
surface then you can process them let
out the emotions cry scream shake
whatever and then through this mdma
effect on the amygdala and the
hippocampus it helps you
store these memories into long-term
storage so that they're not always about
to happen they're in the past
they're part of your story but they're
not the whole story so we discovered
that the dissociative subtype
works better now none of this would be
enough
unless safety so from a safety
perspective
what we discovered is that there was one
woman in the study that attempted to
kill herself twice
during the study there was another woman
that was
so um worried that she might kill
herself that the therapy brought these
things to the surface that she's been
pushing away that she
checked herself into a hospital in order
to avoid self-harm
at the end of the study you know what we
learned is both of them were in the
placebo group
we didn't have anybody in the mdma group
attempt to kill themselves
so the mdma is really
helpful for giving people a sense of
hope
yeah and and that they can somehow
process this
now it's not to say that nobody will
ever commit suicide and
that's our big concern in the second
phase three study
as i said it's more going to be about
safety than about efficacy we think
we'll get the efficacy but
we're very concerned about you know
safety
because we had problems in the first
phase three study of somebody trying to
kill herself twice in the placebo group
you know it's it's the background for
having ptsd
so there'd have to be a disproportionate
number of people in the mdma group
try to kill themselves or succeed in
killing themselves then in the placebo
group for the fd to say oh this mdma
it's too dangerous it brings we don't
think that's going to happen
so those are the other findings are that
this
from safety is that the side effects are
transitory they're minor they're
they're um you know sweating or jaw
clenching or
you know slight temperature increase and
you know ev everybody that's been to a
rave knows about
you know taking ecstasy you know there
are some side effects
um but they're minor they're transitory
and there has been this
massive problem of during the 80s the
90s
night of the nationalists on drug abuse
was trying to say that mdma was
neurotoxic
and that you take it and it's going to
cause nerve terminal degeneration it's
going to be major brain damage it's
going to be significant functional
consequences
and back then they were saying that mdm
is too dangerous it should never even be
researched nobody should even get it
once
because it's poison and brain damage
well
we no longer believe that that was
exaggerated that was um
you know in service of the drug war but
we've done in phase two
um neurocognitive tests before and after
in two of our different sites and showed
no decline in cognitive functioning so
we we don't think that there's any um
neurotoxicity happening
and the doses that we use there's no
obvious
functional consequences people are
getting better and the other thing that
we've learned
in phase two and that we still have to
learn from this study so what we showed
is that
um is the durability of the effect we
showed that um
32 percent of the people that got the
therapy without mdma at two months after
the last experimental session no longer
had ptsd
just with the therapy which is
phenomenal because these are
on average 14 years ptsd one third had
ptsd over 20 years
and just with the therapy
32 percent no longer had ptsd at the two
months
um however those people that got mdma it
was 67 percent
no longer had ptsd you know more than
twice as good
in phase two and in phase three we're
also going to do the 12-month follow-up
that's not for the fda that's not for
approvability that's more for insurance
companies
because this is expensive a lot of
therapy time if it fades
you know if it's great results initially
but then it fades after six months
what's the point and what we showed
in phase two is that um
people keep getting better at the
two-month follow-up
they're doing pretty well but at the
12-month follow-up they're even better
so it's durable people have learned how
to process trauma
they keep getting better so we've not
reached that point in this phase three
study where everybody's got their
one-year follow-up but
we have also done three and a half year
follow-ups to some of the groups that
were in phase two
and showed that it was durable and we're
doing a long
long-term follow-up now to everybody to
many of the people in phase two some of
them treated 15 years ago
so that's all more for the insurance
companies so
basically what we found in the paper
that we just published is that it was
highly efficacious highly significant
no effect by sight works in the hardest
cases
and the safety record was great it's an
incredible success
and that's really exciting especially
given that
the people who've committed who
attempted
to commit suicide were let into the
study and so these are
is the people who are truly suffering
um i mean
that um that's incredibly exciting
and i mean just to speak to the
frustration why things can't move faster
but um
but for what it is it's incredibly
exciting
you